a shocking murder in puerto rico's
raising concern about the safety of
transgender people in the US territory
video taken just before Alex new grounds
final moments last week was posted on
social media it shows her being
threatened and harassed before gunshots
are heard the Governor of Puerto Rico
says all signs in this point to a hate
crime the Human Rights Campaign says at
least 26 transgender or gender
non-conforming people were killed in the
US last year in 91 percent of those
cases were black women and 81 percent
involve people under the age of 30 or
lead national correspondent David magno
traveled to Puerto Rico to investigate
the story this is very upsetting David
good good morning to you what do you
know good morning to you so her name was
Alexa that's who she told people she was
we know very little about her and her
family is not talking a transgender
person like Alexa is someone whose sex
assigned at birth is different from who
they know they are on the inside so far
her killer or killers have not been
arrested and it appears as though a
false narrative spread on social media
and that led people to defame Alexa and
may have driven some to target threaten
and kill her
Alexa used the women's restroom at this
McDonald's in Toa Baja Puerto Rico
police tell us someone accused her of
putting a mirror under a bathroom stall
to peep on people but the police say
there was no proof of that
after the McDonald's incident people
started to shame Alexa on social media
crazy guy dressed as a woman one post
read be careful and watch out that false
narrative spread like wildfire Andy
Torres says he watched in horror as the
hate built on social media he met Alexa
last November como el apoyo se to
embellish a Tala EULA he saw her lying
on a bench looking scared papasano
contigo
but any familiar on the night Alexa was
murdered Torres says he sat at home
responding to those hateful social media
posts well no we done told you
they sent P mi corazon can O'Malley Vega
police tell us those social media posts
may have motivated three
eighteen-year-old young men to threaten
Alexa and record it in that recording
something is shot at Alexa police are
investigating whether it was a pellet
gun a paintball gun or a handgun with a
silencer the 29 year olds body was found
on the side of the road shot multiple
times 12 9-millimeter bullet casings
were found at the scene police believe
those three teenagers left and came back
to the scene and they think they either
committed the murder or they know the
person who did Alexa's murder has
shocked the conscience of people in
Puerto Rico and horrified the
transgender community of which 27 year
old Maria is a part of we might not be
killed but a lot of us live feeling like
we're dead we don't even have access to
identify ourselves we lose respect from
our families from our friends we have a
hard time going to the bathroom we have
a hard time getting a job we have a hard
time building a life in general Alexa
was homeless she had apparently cut off
ties with her family but in the end it
was the family that was required to
claim her body
they had it cremated here and opted not
to have a funeral service cannabis
Walesa mi amiga a mere mana hint they
come there that means son what did you
learn from her Harpham
El Vedado Dordogne Salamanca Preciado ma
incendio de nuevo la llamada de juego
para mantener Mela PA la vieja is a gilt
Redondo semi her passion in life it
seemed as though alexis suffered
silently and in death she was humiliated
publicly and may have been killed
because of an accusation that was never
proven to be true so about that mirror
which someone says Alexa used to spy on
someone in the bathroom which the police
say they found no proof of nandi Taurus
is Alexa used to use that mirror to
watch her back and see who was behind
her Porto Rico Police Department is
leading this investigation the FBI could
come in and open a hate crime
investigation but so far they have not
and the question this morning is why not
the day Alexa was murdered was her
birthday just one sad detail after I
really admired mr. Torres though number
one didn't really know her was just
trying to help another human being I
hope he's right that this will shock
people into saying we need to do better
ignited a flame within him he said but
it should ignite a flame with others as
well and it looks like he tried very
hard I work so very hard and and he more
than anyone just wanted this story to be
told all right David thank you